so just how concerned should we be about
the temperatures we're about to see in
the next 48 hours or so
yes thank you yes i'm from the met
office here at the uh the operations
center um the heat wave is going to
extend over two days today there's a
good chance we're going to break the uk
record of 38.7
tonight would be very oppressive i mean
it's exceptionally difficult sleeping
conditions and tomorrow is the day where
we are really concerned about there's a
good chance now of hitting 40 or 41
degrees celsius and and with that all
the health risks that come with with
those higher temperatures
now i've just laid out some of the
things that people can do to try and
keep themselves cool but do we need to
be prepared paul that this could be the
way that summers are for the foreseeable
right yes i mean this is entirely
consistent with climate change um you
know to get 40 degrees in the uk we need
that additional boost from human induced
climate so in that context yes we are
expecting that the sort of levels of
extreme heat that we're going to expect
tomorrow could be a regular occurrence
by the end of the century
and the temperatures we're seeing over
the next couple of days paul i mean we
will have seen the sort of the stats
showing how the temperatures were going
to rise uh a scientist meteorologist
surprised at how quickly we've reached
these 40 degree days
well i've been a meteorologist for about
30 years and i've never seen the charts
that i've seen today
and the speed at which we are seeing
these exceptionally high temperatures
is is is it is broadly in line what was
what we were saying but to be honest as
a meteorologist to see the brutality of
the heat that we're expecting tomorrow
is quite astounding um and it does worry
me a lot and and my colleagues here in
the met office that this sort of
unprecedented heat could be a regular
occurrence by the end of the century and
what will that mean for our everyday
lives paul
well it's yeah it it's we have to adapt
and and be resilient to the changes
coming coming ahead of us and also just
the obvious things about trying to
reduce the impact of climate change you
know just consider some of the aspects
of of reducing your co2 here in the met
office we're moving towards a net zero
policy and it's that approach that in
time hopefully that will filter through
and reduce the impact we are going to
see tomorrow from climate change
now just talk to us about um the he i
mean you've described it as uh brutal
heat we've said that it's going to be
ferocious as well these are really um
descriptive words that we're using to
describe what's happening in the next
couple of days
i mean what's that going to be like when
you find yourself
outside and
which times of the day are we best to
avoid being outside if we can
well the peak of the of the heat is
during the afternoon sort of mid to late
afternoon so that is when the highest
temperatures like to be attained
but i have to say that overnight is also
oppressively hot
and often that's the biggest impact on
health
so in terms of the heat the maximum
temperature during the day in the
afternoon but overnight i also would
recommend that in any way you can try
and cool yourself down because
temperatures in london tonight could be
in excess of 25 degrees
and paul talked to us about you know
we've seen lots of commentary that other
countries deal with these kind of
temperatures all the time why is it
quite so difficult apart from the fact
that we're not prepared for those kind
of temperatures here in the uk it talks
about the strength of the sun at the
hottest times of the day and how
dangerous that can be
right talking to my colleagues in spain
portugal and france over the weekend i
mean they've described this heat as
exceptional too
and they've seen and observed
amazing temperatures and the like i say
the brutality of that impact
in terms of the uk
the heat which is have been affecting
spain portugal and france is drifting
towards us
so it's the activity of that plume
and also us generating our own heat
that's causing the particular problems
for tomorrow
and are we likely to see another plume
another wave of uh heat later on in the
summer because of course it's only it's
only july
right i mean we can't rule it out
um when we look to the future in terms
of the next week forecast there is this
there is an easing of the temperatures
in fact the temperatures start to ease
back to what we described as slightly
above normal from about wednesday
onwards but as we move into august you
just can't rule out another plume as
we're going to see the next couple of
days as you run into to august is
because in the continental europe the
heat is likely to be sustainable and
pretty intense as well through the
course of that month and that goes to
the point about if you are traveling to
the mediterranean and you're
traveling to the continent it's worth
keeping an eye on the forecast because
the temperatures overseas are also
equally very extreme and hot